stop if you would because i just want to
bring in author and journalist jurgen
turdan hoffa he
has spent some time with islamic state
10 days in fact embedded with the
militant fighters
in iraq and syria last year joins us now
via skype
from munich thank you so much for
joining us on sky news this afternoon i
heard you were
speaking on the radio about this very
subject last week
and i wonder if you could first of all
tell us in your opinion
what islamic state wants the west to do
what would they like us to do do you
think
or they would love to see
american or british ground troops
in the islamic state because they want
to fight western troops they don't want
to kill
muslims anymore they are only killing
muslims or most of their victims are
muslims they want to fight against the
champions
champion is the americans and the
british and
also the french people they want to
fight against the world
the western world so they want uh
western forces to be on the ground what
about
bombing airstrikes how do you think they
would react to that they don't
fear airstrikes because airstrikes
are not successful we have seen in
afghanistan we have been
bombarding afghanistan for 14 years and
the taliban
are still as strong as they have been 14
years ago so it's not successful
but it was counterproductive we had
when we started the war on tarot we had
some hundreds
terrorists in the caves of the hindu
bush and now we have hundred thousand
because for every child we kill with our
bombs
we have new 10 new terrorists the
bombing is a terror breeding program and
they know it and therefore they're happy
if we are bombarded
what if they don't fear air strikes and
they don't fear
ground forces what do they fear
i think they would have problems if you
would do three things
if we would stop the delivery of
weapons and arms from the gulf states
saudi arabia etc to the terrorists to
al-qaeda
and troops like that in syria
they would have problems if we would
close the border between
turkey and the islamic state because
every day some 100 or 200 fresh
fighters from western countries or from
other parts of the world
are crossing these borders i've been
crossing this border too
not as a fighter but as an observer they
would have big problems if they wouldn't
get
fresh fighters and they can only fight
and they can
only survive because they have made a
cooperation
with those groups of the iraqi and the
syrian population which are excluded
from the political process
i'm talking about the sunnis for example
in iraq
the sunnis have been excluded after the
american invasion in 2003
completely and therefore they are
tolerating
is and if it would be if you would
succeed in creating a national
reconciliation
in iraq and to make peace
in iraq and if we would be successful
to have a national reconciliation also
in syria
between the regime and some of the
rebels
some parts of the population and if you
would have peace
in syria this would have be a big
problem because
they would be finished like a fish
without water guerrillas need
part of the population supporting them
and
we should do everything to get this
national reconciliation in iraq and this
year and this would be a strategy
which would be very dangerous what about
the
70 000 troops on the ground that our
prime minister has spoken
so much about of late how intimidating
how
threatening uh what might they be able
to bring
to threaten islamic state
you are talking about which troops the
troops of
assad or no no no so the so the british
government as far as our prime minister
is concerned when he was speaking to the
house of commons
last week he talked about 70
000 uh troops pro-syrian
army troops who would be able to be
brought
together not necessarily under one
banner but at the present
they are rebels in varying parts of the
country
they could be brought together to fight
islamic state
i don't see these 70 000 effective
fighters fighting the islamic state i
don't see them
i see only iraqis
unified iraqis and unified syrians
fighting against is and the rest
of all these armies and all these
discussions will not solve the problem
i don't i think we don't have up to now
really a strategy to defeat isis and we
should have a strategy
and it should be a political strategy
because isis
is extremely dangerous for me personally
it's the most dangerous terror group
in humankind history they are incredible
because it's a combination
of fanaticism and military drill
and that's a dangerous very dangerous
combination
i wonder if i might be able to talk to
you about your time when you were
embedded with
islamic states that our prime minister
has referred to them
as a death cult how would you describe
them
the is fighters yes
for me they are criminals
for me they are terrorists but they are
unislamic
terrorists whatever they do has nothing
to do with islam because islam
doesn't allow compulsion in religion
they force people to believe what they
believe
islam doesn't allow to kill innocents
they kill
innocents every day islam doesn't allow
to destroy churches synagogues or
mosques
but that's what they are doing every day
so
it's an islamic terrorist movement
which is extremely brutal but there
the fact that they are very brutal is
their strategy because they want to
spread fear among
their enemies and they want to provoke
us
to do silly things and we have done
silly things in afghanistan we have done
inacceptable things i'm a former judge
unacceptable things in iraq and they
want to provoke us to do
similar things and they want
to have to to to disperse
to destroy the friendship between
muslims and non-muslims in the western
countries
and we shouldn't fall in that trap
yoga i wonder if i can ask you about the
time that you spent
with islamic state first of all
we have seen what they have done to
westerners over the last
18 months two years so i wonder about
your emotions
as as you went to spend time with them
and also what did you see while you were
there
i saw many things i had a list and i
would say 70
of the things i wanted to see i could
see and
i saw horrible things i saw a
kurdish hostage and i spoke to him and
this
these are moments i will never forget
how helpless this man
was when i came back i tried to do
something for him but it was not
possible
i had the i tried to have the
opportunity to speak to john kentley
i they gave me the opportunity to speak
to him but they said
they would film it and i said i cannot
appear in a propaganda film of
of iis of isis but they were ready to
to bring me together with john candley
and they said
they he had prepared a letter for his
family and the letter for
david cameron i tried to contact
your government when i came back but
your government
refused to do anything and told me that
i
could step out of this question i think
it's a pity because
they were ready to give freedom to
john cantley at a
not for much money they they asked the
release of a
not very important uh woman
so there was a possibility but i was
told
not to to
stay in this problem and
for example i spoke to a judge i have
been
on many places difficult to tell the
whole story of 10 days
but i spoke to a judge about the
executions and amputations
and i said are there new amputations
within the next days or execution he
said no
because we have done some amputations
and now we don't need
anymore we need don't need them anymore
because
the population is doing what we want
them to do
and at this moment when this judge told
me no
you cannot see amputation the execution
i didn't want to see them
i just wanted to know what was happening
one of our is fighters who was always
with us he told me oh
if you would like to take a film about
amputations or execution i can't do that
for you
our prisons are full with prisoners and
you know you just have to tell me
if you would like to have a shia or a
kurd
and if you would if you would like to
have an amputation or an
execution so you can imagine
how difficult these discussions are
these moments are when
when you see that that somebody is
proposing you to kill somebody
or to to
to destroy somebody just because
he wants to do you a favor this is a
gang
of brainwashed terrorists which
is unfortunately extremely dangerous
because the country
they have created to say the state they
have created
is bigger than uk and therefore i still
think we are underestimating
them if we think we just can bombard
them
and then they will disappear they will
not disappear without their mouths
like the taliban didn't disappear did
you fear for your own safety when you
were spending that time with them
yeah we had some difficult moments
our driver was probably 99
jihadi john so you can imagine that
you you have situations which are
difficult i discussed with them quran
i told them that i thought that they
were un
islamic 113 of 114
of the chapters of the sewers of
the quran starts with the words in the
name of god
the merciful the most merciful
and i said where is your mercy so we had
this kind of discussion every day and
they didn't like it
at all but i think if you go
to to such a place if you join
terrorists
you don't have the possibility and you
don't have the right
to have too many emotions because then
you have lost
you are lost if you decide to climb to
the mount
everest you should think about it
if you can do it but if you start
climbing then you should
you don't have the possibility to fear
it anymore
our situation there was no time fear
anything
no time for emotions we had to ask
questions we had to
open our eyes we had to write down what
we have seen where to film what we
have seen and to report it to the world
and
my message is this is the most dangerous
islamic movement terrorist movement in
the world in world history
and we should have more intelligent
solutions and
in the fighting against them we must
leave it there it's fascinating to talk
to you german author and journalist
spend ten days embedded with islamic
state fighters we appreciate you taking
the time to talk to us today thank you
thank you very much more in just a
moment